si mode süskind bonjour je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france alors malgré la loi
sur l'illégalité des colonies
israéliennes comment est-ce que vous
expliquer qu'elle attire les sociétés
internationales mais je pense que les
sociétés internationales investissent là
où elle dit tout est trouvent leur
intérêt est donc ça s'est fait un peu
sous le radar pendant des années et des
années puisque la l'occupation
israélienne remonte à 1967 l'occupation
des colonies israéliennes des
territoires palestiniens occupés et donc
je pense qu'il est très important de
d'attirer l'attention et de pointer du
doigt ces entreprises financières et ses
entreprises qui soutiennent la
colonisation dans les territoires
occupés puisque au regard du droit
international
c'est que le nid sont illégales donc
tout ce qui se fait de l'autre côté de
la ligne verte est illégal aux yeux du
droit international alors quel type de
société sont sont concernés sous quelle
forme elles investissent dans ces
colonies israéliennes
vous avez la foi des banques des
sociétés financières et vous avez aussi
des entreprises qui directement
investis dans ces colonies et s'éteint
c'est une atteinte réellement au droit
international et je pense qu'un rapport
comme celui-là
en pointant du doigt et en mettant ces
entreprises financières ces entreprises
face à leurs responsabilités
créer un malaise puisque plusieurs de
ces entreprises par exemple un grand
fonds de pension norvégien
s'est retirée de plusieurs entreprises
qui financent et la colonisation sous la
pression de ce genre de rapport et on
colle l'objectif c'est de faire en sorte
de kit de de les mettre devant leurs
responsabilités et de les contraindre de
l'est est aussi le contraindre des états
qui sont investisseurs dans certaines de
ces grandes entreprises financières de
faire pression sur ces entreprises pour
qu'elle se retire et donc par exemple se
levait quiconque grandes entreprises
multinationales mais belge
investi dans des aidantes dans du
matériel aaa a vendu du matériel qui
permet de détourner les canalisations
d'eau de des villages palestiniens dans
certaines régions de la cisjordanie est
d'amener l'eau directement ses colonies
et donc c'est tout à fait inacceptable
et inégale il ya bnp paribas aussi qui a
impliqué le gouvernement belge qui est
également actionnaire de bnp paribas du
coup est ce que le gouvernement belge
devrait selon avoir des comptes à rendre
aujourd'hui d'un point de vue juridique
il semblerait que le gouvernement belge
a commencé à aa à s'occuper et apprendre
à s'occuper de ce problème on ya
quelques mois d'ailleurs on n'a pas
encore vu de résultats mais l'objectif
aussi d'un rapport de ce genre et des
associations qui en sont signataires
c'est de faire pression sur le
gouvernement belge pour qu'il se
désengage europe et fassent pression sur
paris bâle puisqu'il il possède 7 7% à
peu près des avoirs de bnp paribas mais
finalement est-ce que les moyens de
pression aujourd'hui ils sont réels ils
peuvent exister ou alors il ya des
moyens de coercition qui sont possibles
c'est très compliqué parce que le
système
israélien est très très très fort et
très beaucoup de poids
auprès à la fois des états des états
européens on l'a bien vu lors de la
dernière intervention militaire
israélienne à gaza il ya quelques mois
l'union européenne est très que dix ans
a très peu d'impact sur
le gouvernement israélien est donc
l'objectif en pointant du doigt et en
mettant et je pense que c'est très
intéressant parce que ça me met en sa
pointe du doigt aussi auprès des
opinions publiques ici en europe et en
particulier je parle de la belgique la
responsabilité de ces entreprises est
séché ming en fait c'est à dire voilà
ils sont ils sont responsables et je
pense que ça a nasa devrait avoir un
impact pour ça a un impact en visibilité
en visibilité en cette saison ces
entreprises de les contraindre la preuve
on l'a dit il ya deux minutes la norvège
le fonds de pension norvégien à cause de
ce malaise que cela a suscité s'est
retiré et l'objectif c'est que d'autres
grandes entreprises financières avec le
soutien de certains gouvernements se
retire de ce qui est considéré comme
illégal au regard du droit international
et sans les investissements de ces
entreprises les colonies israéliennes ne
pourrait pas se développer aujourd'hui
ça ça fait israël est beaucoup moins
dépendants de ce genre de financement
mais il n'empêche que quand on voit les
sommes qui sont investis sacre ça
forcerait les autorités israéliennes et
les mouvements des colonies à chercher
d'autres sources de financement et ça
créerait surtout un mouvement et ça
c'est très important
au niveau de l'opinion publique
européenne en particulier qui en faisant
pression sur ces gouvernements
obtiendrait que tout ce qui se fait de
l'autre côté de la ligne verte à savoir
dans les territoires palestiniens
occupés tous les investissements sont
inacceptables et ce serait une pression
politique important merci beaucoup un
simone süskind avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes militante pour la
paix au proche orient et ancien
parlementaire belge